what the is going on I like to party
Jesus honey wax this is unwaxed get in
lizard we're going shopping with Sophia
and cine Salone did we just become best
friends
y hello everybody and welcome back to
another great episode of the unwax
podcast with your favorite sisters
Sistine and Sophia if you guys don't
know our names by now I can telled by
the tone of your voice how
unenthusiastic you are right now why why
are you calling people out about that no
no no we can talk about it because I'm
stressed too we just got some
pretty heavy not heavy just scary news I
it's just scary meaning our wallet is
scared our wallet is a little scared
this is the problem okay so anyone that
knows throwing a party in general knows
the um the stret that goes behind you
know throwing a party whether it's the
invites the decorations most importantly
the cost see I don't think we thought
that far ahead let me just give some
context Sophia and I thought we thought
we're moving to a new City Halloween is
our favorite holiday let's throw a huge
Halloween party and that'll be the best
way to basically announce that we're in
New York it's going to gather all these
old Friends new friends and we kind of
wanted to do this every single year so
we're like this will be the first year
first annual Stallone Halloween party
now we were a little ambitious on this
I'm not going to lie now that I'm
thinking about it someone actually said
this to me and said wow it's pretty
ballsy that you're throwing a massive
Halloween party to a brand new city
where you only know like a handful of
people from the last six months five
people and we have to fill a venue for
250 people here's the thing here's the
problem I Now understand why people
people get stressed before throwing a
party I feel like I'm I want to throw up
at every given moment I'm stressed that
no's going to show up uh I'm stressed my
costume is too [__] I'm stressed about
everything we're so stressed you guys do
you want to know what we were supposed
to do this morning for the
podcast I bought Sophia and I bald caps
okay and I thought wouldn't that be so
much fun if we dressed as pit for this
episode but the reason why we decided
also against this is one because we're
stressed out but two when this episode
releases it is way past it's November so
why would we show up as Mr 305 also was
thinking about our lovely producer Chris
and I was like he's going to be so
scared when he thinks we're showing up
in two bald headed girls with mustaches
Mr 305s come to this podcast exactly
that's what I'm saying and so I'm
thinking okay we can't do that and um I
just don't have the patience to glue on
a bald cap when I'm sweating and
freaking out myself it will slip off my
face yes so will the mustache I think I
think we're stressed because we just got
a call that we were going to have
sponsors help fund this party just
kidding no one wanted to no one wanted
to so we are taking a huge hit right now
like really my jaw is broken Sophia was
considering let's just cancel the whole
thing let's take I was like let's just
take the L let's let's hopefully if we
have to we put a down payment on it so
maybe we just
here's thing choke on that and let that
go I think we should just start
brainstorming quick creative ways to
make money fast no but I'm worried about
now not even the cost cuz like cost we
kind of we can't get out of it we signed
we signed with a pen and paper that is
locked we are married to that you know
what also this is a lesson really quick
before you go
on read the fine print we did no we
didn't Sophia we did Sophia we did we
just signed and sent we should have read
the guy goes oh it was in the initial
contract we went back we're like he's
full of [__] no it's not we read it
again it was but we were told that that
was going to be yeah but words not our
problem now it's our problem words are
words I know that's the problem was we
we take people's word but now I'm
freaked out because we have to pay for
it and we
will is the people who is going to come
we have not filled it yet I'm freaking
out like we have not hit the max amount
you guys we're so desperate people are
saying that they're gonna float in and
out we're so desperate for this party to
be full that I've invited every person
I've ever gone on one date with
literally W no I am try and they're
going you ghosted me but here's your
invitation it's actually so true so by
the way I'm considering doing that you
should this I'm considering it I
actually just sent to three people like
hey do you have any friends that you
want to include no this is like the
ghost of boyfriend's past I am going to
be horrified all night cuz I'm going to
have every single guy that I've ever had
an awkward first kiss with a bad first
date with and this is the thing the the
the place that we're throwing it at is
having other Halloween parties not that
night at that club but they're having
more and so our guy that's helping us
plan this is saying oh we're going to
send this out this is going to become a
thing people show the next night is
diplo's party so no one's going to go to
our party they're going to go to Diplo
the next day so that is going to go to
she's twice in a row no one back in
August when we came up with this
brilliant idea it seemed like one of our
finest moments it was just the stars
were aligning we were so hyped up I
thought it was so cool I was like
everyone else is going to be so jealous
here's the thing on this list we're
going to do it we cannot back out now
we've already put too much time energy
and money into it I can't wait to come
back to this podcast after the party and
just tell you guys of the horrific fun
we we're hoping it's a success we really
are but yeah why don't you tell them
what you're going to be I'm you know I
honestly my thought has been so invested
in this party that I didn't even I was
so overwhelmed about finding a costume
choosing a costume as a girl even just
in general for anybody it's hard it's
really hard because you're trying to
find like what's not super cliche what
would work with my vibe blah blah for me
I just ended up I'm doing October Fest
I'm a beer girl I'm doing the you know
the classic even your costume is lame a
beer
girl really it's lame I mean it's we've
seen it a million times you're a maid
that is the most basic I'm October Fest
she is a literal French maid I spoke too
soon yeah that now that I hear it back
now that I'm hearing it now it it does
sound a little you kidding me it does
sound a little yeah I'm doing some cute
stockings this's wearing lingerie with a
a feather duster are you kidding me
mine's lame yours is the least creative
one out of the two of us made by the way
you should be thinking me cuz I'm
cutting down a cost with my costume okay
because I can stay after and clean I'm
already in the proper attire we don't
need to hire Cleanup Crew I got my
feather duster yeah yeah cuz at 5:00
a.m. you're going to be picking up beer
bottles if it'll save me a dollar I will
I will at this point I'll do anything
for a dollar at this point it's bad but
you know what we're excited we're
[__] oursel I have nervous sweats
yeah we're in a little cranky mood but
we're going to keep on trucking with
this just like your hat all right all
right let's to switch gears um this has
been also something that has been stuck
on my mind and I keep getting reminded
about this probably once a week is the
fact that I'm single and not just single
not married everyone in my life is
engaged married or pregnant with their
first child yeah and that is something
that is 27 it's well 27 to 30 I'd say
which makes sense because I a lot of
these couples met in college or whatever
maybe they met in their early 20s and
they just got really lucky sopia is
literally always the bridesmaid never
the bride liter literally how does that
actually make you feel cuz I know with
the brain that you have you're probably
spinning
out um yeah no you know what it is that
I've been saying this and I don't know
if anyone else feels like this but for
me I really want to be in love I want to
get married like I would be if I found
my guy right now I would for sure in the
next like year and a half want to get
proposed to have a wedding and have a
kid like I like I love love and so you
do too so for me it's like the next
person I'm dating is like so I'm taking
dating very seriously because you
actually are and so for me it's like the
next person I'm serious with is going to
be someone that I see and I just know
that that will be my person so I am
feeling the weight of watching everyone
have their person and I just don't yet
and it's so cute but I'm also just like
it always you know what makes you look
Inward and you think what's wrong with
me why can't I find a good guy why is it
so hard I'm putting myself out there
nothing's
clicking and I don't have a follow-up to
that I'm really asking like the universe
why me why why me why me but like maybe
it's because I'm not maybe I'm not ready
yet maybe I'm not the in my life be
honest if this is going to be an insult
no it's a hypothetical question okay do
you think you're really ready to take on
the responsibility of being a wife and a
mom in the next three years oh yeah
that's when I'm 30 are you kidding yeah
Absol take age out of it 100% 3 years
really you don't think that you could no
to give you a compliment I can see you
actually getting engaged and then the
next 3 years if you were with the person
that you loved there's way by the way
you've also told me that you could do
that yeah I still where where is this
coming from all a sudden like no maybe
not because we put so much pressure on
oursel to find the perfect guy right now
yeah that that's maybe why it's not
happening we are truly [__] blocking
oursel for
example are you okay with combining
closets sharing a bathroom sharing a bed
we're in a very selfish
age like and you're supposed to be
you're 27 and 25 it should be all about
you and growing and no you're shaking
your head now no I mean sine sharing a
toilet is not like the biggest of my
problems like I don't care if I have to
share a for yourself if I have to share
a closet that's not that big of a deal
for me like that's not Sophia sine we
have a lot of stuff that's fine okay
we're just G to have agree to disagree
but you're also 25 for me I'm not saying
I'm I'm actually I'm actually not
putting pressure on myself I just see it
around me and I'm already have my entire
Pinterest page for my wedding already in
SPO out but I love I like I love it I
love watching my friends get married I
get so excited and I'm like oh my God
tell me all about it I'll be like a if
you need a bridesmaid like I'll be
another brid you that friend that you're
so excited but secretly you're like why
isn't it me no no no no thankfully I
actually excited for my friends but then
I think about um when is it going to be
my turn but that's just that's just me
in my head and that's me overthinking
you personality fun there's not one
friend of mine that I see getting
married anytime soon so maybe it's just
because you're around it around all the
time like none of my friends are stable
enough for a husband right now none yeah
well I I don't know I it definitely is
in timing like right I would say though
I would not envision myself last year or
the year before or anything like that
getting I'm like not even close and I'm
still not putting pressure on myself I
mean I would even went to like a I went
and saw like a fertility specialist in
case I wanted to like freeze my exgs in
the future just because that yeah well I
went because I was having that you know
weird pressure just thinking like am I
behind like I now I'm single and
everyone is at this next phase of their
life and blah blah blah and I wanted to
see options in case like you know if I
don't find my person at 30 like what can
I what can it what can I do and so one
of the options is you know freezing your
eggs I'm not doing it yet but it was
nice to get that information in here
okay you know you can do this and your
eggs are going to be great until you're
at 80 years old you can put your 27 year
old eggs in you and it would still work
like it's CRA you've always been really
good about planning out your future in
that way yeah I really wanted you to
freeze your eggs this year cuz I wanted
to give you the injection every day oh
just a little satisf this is also this
is the problem I would consider doing it
if I hit 30 and I was still single and
like no man in sight but I have a huge
fear of needles so I'm not sure how I
would execute this you know what you
need though also we're not going to be
living together by 30 huh yeah um well
I'm younger than you so that's then you
live with Scarlet
what what are you talking about no my
roommate she's going to live with her
boyfriend me alone no you give have a
friend I'll get a cat just find one on
the
street you so so you're not even around
it because you went to one of my friends
weddings and you were did you feel it
though like don't you when you're around
it you feel it and you want to have it
not particularly oh I've never been one
of those girls that had the Pinterest
board had the baby names picked out had
that know what kind of cut ring I want I
don't you tell me cushion diamond cut I
don't know the difference I love love
and I love all of that you know what you
read too much that's your problem yeah I
think I have a very false version of you
read too much you know what it is I
don't read so that's why I'm stable with
my love life she's a hopeful romantic
I'm a hopeless romantic because
everything is hopeless you know also
your problem is Sophia you're writing a
book about love right now I know and
it's on your mind it's about weddings
too my God maybe you should talk write a
book about divorce no because I that's
horrible well do some research and then
maybe see oh there's no point in rushing
this I did read something about divorce
I heard that divorce is going down
slightly this year well I think Co
definitely spiked it yeah well yes Co
spiked breakups and stuff but I heard
that marriages this year there's just a
a slight yeah less of rate of divorce so
woo woohoo we made it I I don't really
know what we were making but I think you
need to have a backup plan yeah I will
my backup plan is already set and
secured I've had a conversation with my
backup plan about this what do you mean
you you talk to a listen this is my
ideal situation if all hell breaks loose
and I am just alone and single and sad
and I'm 35 and there's literally no one
else for me if my backup plan is also
single we're just going to get married
you have a plan
man I do and it's it's not a bad option
is he a little boring yeah but his
parents are great he doesn't listen he
definitely doesn't listen to this his
parents are great so it would just be it
would be a good family Vibe but that's
my is the person I'm thinking you're
thinking of yes okay person's calling me
right
now he heard you I heard you said he
says I do no he like go outside he's on
a knee that's wait so when did you make
this packed
a few weeks ago this is a recent pack
we're getting old
Sophia you're
25 don't include me in this we're
getting old oh my God you know saying
that I'm 27 sounds like I'm already
basically 30 I'll also tell you why I
don't think you're ready for a
husband why
sinee don't get mad I could feel you
getting mad yes because this was a
totally different conversation
because you would scare him with your
mouth
tape okay you look like you're from
Silence the Lambs thanks for calling me
out and I'm sorry I don't think a guy in
the romcoms that you watch they wake up
next to the girl and her hair is perfect
and her Skin's glowing and she's wearing
the most luxurious lingerie night dress
and you're there with tape all over your
mouth like you just got your lips sewn
shut yeah I look like I'm being
kidnapped so not exactly hot okay well
if people don't know what mouth taping
is which it is a fad and it's a good
thing it is basically supposed to force
you to use your nose when you're
sleeping and not your mouth like mouth
breathing is apparently really bad it
bad breath and it's just supposed to be
good for your overhaul you have a deeper
sleep and so one time I slept with cinee
and she thought I looked horrifying
because I was she like try to talk to me
and I tape all over my mouth no the
funniest thing that happened the other
day was she comes running into my room
in the morning she goes sine sinee I'm
freaking out I'm freaking out I go
what's wrong with she goes I swallowed
it I said swallowed what she goes the
tape I can't find it and this has
happened like twice already you keep
eating it I keep eating my mouth tape
but I don't think so you're telling me
that I have health issues because I
mouth breathe yeah you're eating tape
that's probably poisonous edible I'm
assuming that they add insurance and
assume that this would be a possibility
my God yeah I've swallowed it twice but
I feel like it has to be somewhere in my
bed I'm still looking around I when I'm
going to like clean my bed tomorrow and
just see if I can find it because I I
refuse to believe I was swallowing you
actually have been doing I've been doing
too many things lately Sophia is the
type of person where if she gets a
routine down she'll switch it when it
comes to skin care products supplements
and you're never consistent well you've
always been very consistent with all of
it you've always been extremely you know
you find the right products for yourself
if it's not broken don't like try to fix
it you know I'm the opposite my skin
looks perfect my hair is
glowing I think okay let me just like
switch it up let me just use a new
product so let me explain this this is
horrible horrible so I'm I love like
Health trends like if there's anything
trending healthwise I'll do it tape Tik
Tok case Point close so like chlorophyll
chlorophylls that that uh it's you put
in your water it becomes green it's
supposed to it tastes like pennies it's
it tastes like you're eating manure it's
really bad and it's supposed to like
detox your system so I did that for a
week I started getting on probiotics cuz
my gut was horrible have you ever tried
seel no I've been wanting to which I
should want to cuz I shouldn't but so
I've done I did all of this for two
weeks and the see get ATT tested this I
did all of these Trends the mou taping
the probiotics the the green water
literally last week I had for the first
time ever massive cystic acne all over
my face in the middle of the night I
woke up that's what's so messed up
everywhere you take all of these things
thinking it's going to improve your
health and I'm not kidding you not
saying this is an insult you've never
looked worse and you were doing too much
yeah it's really bad like apple cider
vinegar gummies I was doing like new new
facials I it's bad and I I just know it
makes my skin worse and I showed I woke
up I was like so see look and she
actually gasped that's how bad it was
yeah no it wasn't good it wasn't good
I'm not going to sit here and say that
my routine is great because I actually
have a lot of really bad habits that I
need to break but at least to keep it
simple you eat the same thing every
single understand but I would say in
terms of skin care my skin care I would
compare it to like a middle-aged man's
like one cleanser one moisturizer that's
it you don't do like uh n you don't do
vitamin C nothing hyaluronic acid
nothing nothing nothing and do you see
do you see anything on my face because
you don't need that much you really
don't I've seen differences and I don't
well you I don't know I just I like my
like eight SE routine and then my you
know what's so funny I was going out
with this guy once and his nighttime
routine was longer than mine and he had
all the serums the products the pills
the everything how's the skin it was
okay but in my head I was like someone
cooked here he didn't do this as no he
didn't know what any of this was someone
cooked here yeah and I appreciate her
for that I really do I know when you see
like a guy that has shampoo conditioner
body wash a body soap face like face
wash in a shower but tell me it's not
the most frustrating thing cuz I'm going
off topic a little bit go ahead when you
take in the boy right and you improve
pretty much everything about him his
style the way he Styles his hair like
his skin care routine like his the way
he eats food like everything's healthier
right girlfriend air girlfriend air and
then they just become a better version
of themsel right and even just the
little things like they know how to be a
better boyfriend how to court you better
everything smell better and then you
guys break up and then some other girl
gets this new new and improved guy and
she's like wow man of my dreams I go I
put in two years two years into this he
was in that oven I was spicing him yeah
I was cooking him yeah and he came out
baked for some other girl to eat he was
like a bread right and he rose he
roasted the occasion but for the wrong
girl for the wrong girl I know you need
to get a sliver I got the end you got
the end got the butt piece
got the breakup butt piece that's what
I'm saying that's so true it's bad but I
will go back to my routine it's so bad I
looked this up the other day I have an
issue since I've been calling you out
this whole episode I have another issue
with me no with me oh I'm going to throw
myself under the bus never
happens I have oral
fixation
it does not sound what you think it's
sounding
like it does sound like what it's
sounding like but it doesn't mean what
she's meaning um okay so I have this I
think it's an OCD thing that I have yeah
it's an anxiety OCD and just a horrible
habit you have it started with gum and I
chew gum every minute of every single
day except when I'm shooting this
podcast guys 8:00 a.m. she wakes up and
grabs coffee
8:30 three pieces of gum and then it's
12:00 another three pieces of gum I
would say you're missing all the times
that I sneak past you no no [__] no I
know because by the way this is the
craziest part we get the car pack Mentos
gum the 60 pieces we get four of them
four I'm not even joking four of them oh
my God we have to go to Dwayne Reed
probably three times a week to refill
these bottles
she is chewing gum from 8:00 a.m. to
literally 10:00 p.m. at night okay
non-stop I Googled the definition so
people understand what oral fixation is
it's defined as an oral condition
involving a person who has unconscious
obsession with their mouth so they need
to constantly suck okay or chew
something um now what does it mean now
to chew a lot of gum no no no you jaw
problems like TMJ tooth decay gum
disease ow here are the causes it does
help your jawline I may die of a disease
but wait this says it's because I was
weaned off of breastfeeding too soon e
okay Mom blame mom for this yeah who
else am I going to blame cuz you didn't
have this disorder until New York is
this a disorder I'm I'm calling it a
disorder an obsession an addiction
whatever it is because it is it's
ridiculous another bad habit that I have
is I hate the taste of water so I use
those little flavor water drops I use me
she needs like she can't taste just
plain water like she has to put some
sort of like lemon flavoring or whatever
it is and one bottle has about
50 uses so it's like one bottle could
fill 58 Oz Waters right I go through a
bottle every 3 days no guys and it's she
doesn't like the thing is when you're
squirting it in there it's like squirt
done she
goes saturate that [__] but that must be
so bad for you your Puma smells so bad
I'm not going to lie Sophia you drink
chlorophyll who knows the color who
knows the color piss you have actually
if you actually want to read online
actually go ahead um it's supposed to
help the smell of your body so um I had
no so you have Bo I didn't have any when
I was drinking that now you have Bo
again no I would say I'm pretty clean
but like I guess it's not as great as it
was when I was drink
chlorop but yeah no it's it's bad wait a
minute this says that it starts at the
age of puberty your gum oral fixation oh
wait what I'm on the wrong oral website
hold on wait anyway what website are you
looking at for puberty health.com okay
well don't look at that you're obsessed
with it and I think it's a bad habit and
you need to stop but you know how you
have certain habits that you want to
hide from your partner and you're just
like my your partner no cuz I'll do
anything in front of you but like that's
one of them for sure oh yeah for sure oh
yeah You' have to hide mouth taping and
stop drinking green water and I just
have to stop putting I used to bring me
in my P to restaurants and I couldn't do
that now do you really want to sacrifice
the things that make you happy for a man
well no I would just say you need to
tone down the chewing gum cuz having 60
or 120 pieces a week is probably not the
healthiest cuz maybe you should Che one
a day sopia you're a walking pimple and
you're going to give me advice I don't
have pimples anymore they're healing
she's in her healing girl phase I like
healing I know girl era you know oh
that's reminded me of girl math I love
Trends I like Health Trends you like the
trends when it comes to anything
involving like women's psyche yeah you
love like those psych ones like how to
um like psychology of how to trick a guy
into like oh my God this is the best one
they said best way to intimidate someone
stare at their hairline when they're
talking to you Sisty was just staring at
my hairline last night be like am I you
like I don't know what you're looking at
I know wait I'm obsessed with girl math
right now it's so funny do you have any
versions of girl math so girl by the way
girl math is just basically it's a joke
on women saying that we're bad at
budgeting and so for me I'd say my girl
math is when I order something on
revolve or any clothing website and I
return it and it says I get store credit
I made money or like if you pay in cash
like it's not B you didn't actually
spend money if you pay in cash if I pay
in cash oh yeah no I didn't
just my credit card but I feel like for
me girl math is a little different like
I'm like girl math for me is calculating
how many days until I have to wash my
hair oh that's a version yeah yeah like
if I wash it tomorrow then it's going to
get greasy by Friday but if I want it to
be slick back like I can do that for
Thursday craziest that's how I feel
about concerts too like I If I buy a
concert ticket like six months in
advance by the time I made enough money
like that was a free concert or well
we're out at a bar
I am calculating what I think the amount
of alcohol is in each cocktail CU I'm
getting a different cocktail each time
until I'm like okay this was two shots
this was a shot and a shot of per that
is why you don't enjoy drinking when you
go out cuz but then I'm trying to
calculate the perfect Buzz that's so
lame CU I know my limit that's girl math
for me that's a lot of math in my head
that's you can't I would never go out
and calculate exactly the precise amount
of alcohol it's going to take I know
exactly two margaritas here's another
girl math counting how many girlfriends
he has Before It's Too Many girl math
counting how many girlfriends he has
Before It's Too Many I mean that's so
before it becomes like that so specific
for you because I don't even think oh
for me yeah I don't I don't think like
oh he had four girlfriends if he hits
the fifth one it's a bad one I have a
girl math for you that's very specific
for you then okay your girl math is
calculating how many minutes it took for
him to respond for you to counter it
with more minutes that's just me
overthinking a text message that's your
girl math you said gu he took an hour to
respond I'm going to take 93 minutes to
respond that's your girl math it works
you crazy ass Looney man okay that's how
you are with like FaceTime if a guy
calls you you're like I can't call him
back I'll call I'll let him call me back
tomorrow but I can answer it this time
because my makeup will be on at this
time okay but hold
on I'm sad about that what FaceTime sad
about girl brought no no about girl
M I'm sad about that situation that
you're referring to right now about the
face times yes that you yeah what do you
want to elaborate on about it you guys
I'm like
bummed okay everyone has this one person
in their life that is literally their
Achilles heel yeah they could do no
wrong they could hurt you they could
date other people
they could ghost you and every time
they'd call you still want to like
answer there's something that pulls you
to this person this person just drives
me nuts because I have no idea what it
is that he has that cinee cannot let go
of he will literally he'll literally
kick her and she'll come back a month
later being like but he texted me hey I
know and ask to get drinks it's one of
those it's one of those guys that will
just keep you on the world's longest
leash and you feel so special when they
pull it in when they are you know have a
minute in their day or they're feeling
oh it's convenient to talk to her why do
you think this person specifically is
just that I don't know if it's this
person or the way that they're going
about it that's really getting under my
skin I think when you date like everyone
sort of wants to
be the winner like they want to have the
ball in their Court they want to take
charge yeah this is the first time and
I'm a very controlling person where I
don't have control of the situation and
I don't know what his next move is and I
don't know what he's thinking and this
is what makes me sad now I feel like you
do have control of the situation at all
I think you don't think you do no I'm
telling you not at all because he says
last minute the other week let's go get
dinner I said great yeah we go out to
dinner I'm excited it's very casual I
was literally in a hoodie regardless
we're talking it's fun I'm comfortable
I've know known this person for years so
I'm like okay this is just mhm if all
hell breaks loose like this is a great
person to go out with yeah but he
straight up
said he was talking you know when they
just talk in circles and they're saying
a lot of things but it actually means
nothing they're they're not saying
exactly what they want to say but
they're saying every version of it just
say what you want to say so I asked him
and I said what do you want from me
because it's been about 5 years of this
pingpong back and forth no one's saying
what they want he said I'm playing games
I said he's playing games it's baloney
right I said what do you want from
me he said
nothing he said nothing and I guarantee
you what does that
mean because so what nothing means
nothing
nothing but nothing could mean that he
doesn't want nothing now girl mouth wait
five years let him let him cook and then
no it means nothing but it it was just
such an interesting feeling because I
thought we were on the same page of the
amount that we liked each other we just
weren't admitting it I like you right so
I did and I was like I like you what do
you want to do about it and it's just
goes back to that old saying if he
wanted to he would do you feel like that
he'll stop becoming that achillus heel
for you because he admitted that he
doesn't want anything serious
yet cuz he didn't by the way and let's
just preface he wasn't saying like he
didn't want anything with her he
actually does he's just immature young
the thing is boy you can't go out with
someone that doesn't know what they want
and that's what he kept saying I don't
know what I want I don't you know me you
know all my quirks you know my family
you know my personality you know what
it's like to date me you know how I you
know everything about about me right so
either you want it or you don't he's
like oh let's wait another 5 six months
for what I'm not going to change should
I grow another arm then stop answering
his text messages you still do and his
calls let's see what he said right now I
really it's just going to be hey are you
sick are you sick riveting did you truly
a nailbiter conversation was he sick
when you hung out with him no did you
you kissed him right
right
no God damn it why would you ask me that
why would you ask anything you sabotage
you asked you I walked into that one um
so maybe that's why he's asking maybe
he's sick and so he's think your make
out probably gave him he
goes cinee you go on so many dates with
so many
men
and maybe so insulting no it gets worse
do you tell them about every guy you go
out with well yeah that's why it's so
weird cuz it's like a friend but then
there's underlying feelings there like
he'll FaceTime me right and I'm getting
ready for a date and he's like what are
you doing getting ready for a date will
have a great time wow you guys are toxic
with each other this is just it's his
level of unbotheredness that bothers me
he no what I want him to say that should
be me I'm picking you up tomorrow we're
going on a date and said he's just like
have a great time he even told me at the
dinner he said he said even in those
five or six months when we're still
figuring out what we want you can still
see other people I can see other what is
this why you why are we at dinner right
now what we do exactly what are we doing
okay then stop saying yes to these
dinners but let me tell you what he said
it was a very humbling moment oh boy he
goes you date all these people and maybe
instead of blaming all of the men that
you don't have a connection with he put
in airor quotes connection with maybe
it's your lack of willingness to open up
and you have trust
issues
he said that to
you
damn he's ballsy for that one so he's
basically saying it's not them it's you
yes did you have a an internal freak out
I was so close to walking out of there
said do you really think on a first date
with someone I'm just going to open up
my Pandora's box of problem think you do
no I said if anything on a first date I
give the best version of myself I give a
fake version of myself that's probably
the problem what he's referring to oh
please Sophia you know first date's like
a performance it's a job interview
you're doing I always say pretty myself
I told the last guy I had a rash on the
first date oh my God we should talk
about you can we please stop talking
about me I took your phone this weekend
and I made you text a guy actually I
texted him for you oh yeah no we I mean
that's fine we invited him out I mean
you know what it was that just taught me
to not overthink things so cine
basically is referring to we all out at
a bar and she just grabbed my phone and
text us some someone that I was kind of
interested in talking to and I had a
full on freak out she was kind of it did
I had a full freak out um and then he
showed up and it nothing happened but it
was really fun and it just reminded me
that I seriously put so much weight
behind making moves and I didn't realize
that and there's actually no problem in
saying like hey how are you why so
simple why is it so weird for girls to
make the first move I don't know I love
it well this thing in person I make a
first move on text I have such a hard
time being like the first to FaceTime
the first to like say like what are you
doing tonight or like where are you
going because I feel like I don't want
to sound desperate but that's so stupid
like who's who's juding I'm not going to
lie this is what I told her at dinner I
said if I was a dude and you were
calling me saying hey what are you up to
tonight want to come meet me at a bar
what do you think he's going to sit
there and be like who does this girl
think she is like this ugly troll yeah
no are you crazy he's going to be like
yeah sounds great I'll put my shoes on I
know I know and that's so stupid and so
silly because I still have that problem
it's like I have confidence in a lot of
areas but that one I just have such a
struggle with and then I realize after
I'm like thanks sinee well it was
actually a great time it was so great
that I was severely third Wheeling so I
sort of slowly backed away out of the
bar and I said I'm going to leave you to
kids also it was such a great night
other than that because you guys I just
remember this two people came up to me
and said are you favorite book
Club if okay if you're new if you don't
know this but I'm a Avid book person and
I've had a book club for like the last
two years and I love it I'm trying to
make it a thing it's close to becoming a
thing now it's a thing it's a thing
thank you I've people have come up to us
about the podcast about our family blah
blah blah I've never had people come up
to me and said oh like are you favorite
book club are you the book club girl
yeah two two in one night two and one
girl ask for a photo yeah I lost lost my
mind it's actually crazy if you don't
know what your genre is follow her
account she'll get you into reading she
got me into reading thank you I'm trying
I'm trying but it's it's like the girl
keep because I follow every book that
you read and this and this and I
seriously it was you know what it was
and this is like not to get all stoppy
but it was kind of like the first time I
felt I'm doing something right like that
was for me finally seeing hard work pay
off because I think when anyone first
sort of start an Endeavor that they're
really passionate about it takes forever
to see it play out so during that period
of working towards building your brand
you keep questioning is this even worth
it yeah cuz I'm doing like a a book
reviews and videos and this for two
years straight I'm reviewing like three
books every single solit you're very
dedicated and I love it and it's like
the thing is why I do is cuz I love it
so much and then now I get to see
someone say no I love it too like it's
not my mom saying it andine saying like
other people and not my friends are
saying it's like random girls in a bar
that recognized me through like my in
like little videos it's really cool it
was so cool so not only have a cute guy
at the bar that I was flirting with I
also had people coming up to say book CL
and sine thought it she was freaking out
you I was like let me take the photos
this was the coolest thing I think
that's happened to you in a long time
plus you looked so cool in front of that
guy are you kidding me thanks are know
you kidding me oh were PID actors but it
was so cool that I actually just
completely forgot about this until now
too okay so we went to two different
bars this night and um that was
ambitious it was for her I can I can do
it she can't do it she can't hang um you
can hang but bars are not your
thing I can hang but bars aren't my
thing yes you don't like bars or clubs
you like a nice restaurant and maybe
like one bar that's nearby with people
that you know that has a good plan my
thing is take out on the couch that's my
thing I mean that's my that's yeah
that's true probably you're very mobile
for me you're almost too mobile for me I
love I will go if you this I have a
problem saying no Stine's good at
managing her drinking and take like if
my friends are like let's have another
round I'm like okay let's here no so we
went to two different bars but the first
one we're just waiting before dinner
whatever these guys offer us their bar
seats and of course ends up becoming
like oh wor with my girlfriend too so
it's the three of us you have to get
into conversation I was wearing red lips
this night cuz which is very different
for me I hear on besides to talking to
this one guy who she's zero interest in
his name is Mike yeah his name is hi
Mike shout out Mike lives in Hudson
yards I hear her say oh yeah she's a
Marilyn Monroe impersonator no no no I
said cuz Okay let me let me let me give
context when the first girl came up to
you and said can I get a photo right and
I took the photo the guys were like
she's famous what does she do and I said
oh my God what doesn't she do for one
she's probably best known known for
always playing the role of young maryn
in every
movie and they go no way and I'm like
yeah and I also what else did I say I
said you're also you said you said I was
doing a speech at Children's Hospital
Maryland no not just as Maryland I said
they go what else I'm like oh she's an
avid speaker she travels all around the
country she's giving one for Children's
Hospital next month um and my God true
just one but just one but you were
saying that like I was a global World
traveler and they actually didn't we
were related so they go what do you do
I'm like oh I'm super unemployed
actually I'm thank God she took me under
her Wing because she's basically my
sugar mama she pays for everything and
they bought it they bought but this is
the problem too sinee can roll with this
stuff like she actually so on the spot
sine can just formulate the best lie in
everyone will believe her I am so bad at
it like I freak out if I have to tell a
lie like you'll for sure like I'm the
worst liar in the world so St I'm
Marilyn Monroe I'm I'm like no I'm not
no she's like she's being humble like
she was being humble when we left the
bar Mike asked for my number how do you
get out of it I was like okay so I gave
him my number and in the contact I
didn't put my name I wrote friend of
Marilyn no you didn't you did of course
you did but you know oh hack also if a
guy is asking for your number and you
don't want to give it to him be's being
pretty forceful about it my friend
suggested this which was so smart she
said just change the last number of your
cell phone number and then let's say you
happen to run into them the next day or
the like few months later be like oh my
God I must have just mistyped it here's
I never had thought about that before I
do this one all the time what I'm going
to start doing this to the guy that
keeps stringing me
along answer the phone if they call you
and if you don't want to talk to them
and you just want a reason to not speak
at all answer the phone say oh hey how
are you while you're on the phone with
them put airplane mode on because it
will say call failed instead of hung up
oh that's genius so it just seems like
you didn't have Wi-Fi oh that's a good
one I didn't even think about that one
let's get back to last weekend yeah it
was successful you're meeting up with
this guy at the bar I'm literally
standing there as they're trying to
engage in conversation I felt a few
moments where Sophia was side eyeing me
just to Signal like get the [__] away
and I was like I was I hear you loud and
clear I called an Uber I left I said
have fun kids enjoy your night right I
go back home I go up to the apartment
ready to unlock the door check my purse
I don't have a key I said no problem I
go down to the front desk it's been 10
minutes by the way since she's left yeah
I said hey I forgot my key is there a
master key you could just let me in
right he goes yeah sure here it is well
first you didn't believe that you lived
there he was new he was like I but
honestly I admire the love of security
that's true right yeah that's true the
key he gives me doesn't work because
apparently that was for the old locks
yeah so I'm like oh [__] okay so I
texted her I said hey I'm locked out no
answer I call her no answer so now I'm
like oh my God I last time she was out
she was out till 2:30 in the morning
it's 12:30 what am I going to do so I
just um decid I want to go horizontal so
I just start lying in the middle of the
hallway of our apartment building and
I'm just waiting shoes off I'm trying to
I found little candies I had in my purse
just like so to me and I finally look at
my phone after like 15 minutes later and
I see the message sine wrote I'm locked
out and I'm thinking she's such a [__]
block for one thing and two I felt so
bad cuz there was so much buildup to
having this guy come out and for me to
ruin it completely ruined it but this is
the funny part so it was it was me and
my friend and then him and his friend
and so we decideed you know let's just
walk to the apartment it's really close
by we which by the way screw you for
that no screw me I didn't how would I
have known that you were leing
horizontal on the ground if a family
member is locked out of their place you
decide let's take a 20 minute leisurely
walk drunk stumble back instead of a fem
minute car ride as I'm waiting there on
the carpet okay you were fine for one
thing and two I didn't suggest it they
suggested and I wanted to hang out with
them more here's the thing though Sophia
says I'm coming back she didn't tell me
that she was
bringing company with her no I didn't I
just I decided to make it a party this
is why it was bad normally I wouldn't
care that she'd bring someone over right
well look I not someone it wasn't like
me including this guy to like three
people it was yeah it was like I just
want to have friends over
unfortunately that day was not the best
day to have people over yeah actually
now looking at it it was pretty gnarly
because I
decided I'm going to clean out every
makeup drawer every closet I'm going to
this was the gross one I
decided I'm going to wash my clip and
hair extensions Halloween's coming up I
got to get these looking nice I'm so
gross I didn't know you were supposed to
I didn't know that either and the way
you're supposed to do it is you're
supposed to wash it let it soak and then
you hang them do you put shampoo and
conditioners and then you hang them
right so I did that before I left so I
hung like three three sets of hair
extensions all over your bathroom all
over the guest bathroom from the shower
rods from the the faucets from where
they hang the towels literally the
entire and then there was a big ball on
the floor like the entire bathroom so
gross the one that come people use when
they come over cuz I wasn't expecting
people to come over was covered in hair
that Sophia goes right when they walk in
let me give you a tour and I go oh [__]
and they walk in also I had no idea that
this was happening it looked like I
scalped someone yeah that was bad it
looked like a murder scene first off our
apartment itself was just like really
unorganized for some reason the hair
hanging everywhere it looked like yeah C
scalp someone and also she was balding
like it looked like she I know and it's
dark hair so I can't say it was your
hair it was like it's it's pretty gnarly
they must think I have no hair on my
head I the vibe went down I'm not going
to lie the you know what they they left
pretty quickly after after seeing
anything about the what do you think
they're like nice they're like nice
they're like I'm like you guys should
come back over see this is why I can't
be in a relationship I can't do stuff
like that so see you're going to have to
show the guy you're dating that you have
clip-ins for occasions do you know the
links that I've gone to to avoid a man
knowing I have clippin can I say that
I'm actually very impressed because I
have never worn one on a date before and
you're good with like putting them in
and making them hidden I think about
like someone touching my hair and
feeling it one time oh God this is so
bad what one time I was on a date with a
guy we went to dinner and he drove so he
was going to drive me home we're sitting
in his car and I could feel The Vibes I
go okay I know before I get out of the
car there's going to be a kiss yeah okay
oh God and I was like oh
shoot I got four rows of extensions in
my head and you know you know they grab
the back of your head when you're in the
car yeah it's a car make yeah they grab
back your his handle get stuck like
there were so many right this is when I
had blonde fried hair oh so so it's
crunchy so I tried so hard to distract
him the entire way home I would say oh
my God what's that restaurant and then
I'd point so he'd look out of the window
and I'd clip it throw one in my bag and
then I go wait what's this song he'd
change it clip it throw another one in
my bag think you have a dead animal in
there here's the best part oh no so it
was such organized chaos because I
wanted to get them out as quickly as
possible but I couldn't see if they were
fully making in the purse so I get out
of the car we kiss goodbye I grabbed my
purse and as I'm walking to the front
door oh my God what I'm holding my bag
trying to be cool like thanks for
tonight and like look back oh know what
there was literally hair coming out of
the bag like I just decapitated someone
and someone's head was in my purse and
he goes uh sinee I go yeah and he
goes no points at the bag no it was Palm
Beach guy no
Yeah I broke up them next week I was too
embarrassed yes she did I did said you
can't know me anymore for multiple
reasons that would had to be the main
one how embarrassing that's pretty bad
so yeah I don't want a boyfriend
because that's something I I don't want
to shove extensions in my bag anymore
but I do so if you're out there it's too
much work well you know what by the time
this episode comes around maybe we have
found someone at their Halloween party
or maybe no one shows up and that will
be the I can't wait to tell stories of
that party oh you guys the next episode
after this is going to be probably
probably the most Chaotic episode just
knowing what happens to us and what
usually goes down it terrifying it's
going to be bad so next week is going to
be the Halloween party stress the max
sinee is her fake hair is falling out
I'm breaking I'm not even wearing any
right now not now I'm saying before fake
hair is falling out I'm breaking out
that's what my point is and we're going
to be making out at our party not with
each other guys are you kidding me
first of all you think of a bad kisser
so you wouldn't want to anyway no no
you're not my type I don't like blondes
that's that's true she doesn't like
blond I don't like blondes either so
well guys I mean do you like me no sine
stop this is so creepy okay we're going
to end this episode like this but thank
you guys for listening to this once
again messy episode um we're we're
partially freaking out about the party
so maybe our head is not in the right
place but hopefully it is by the time
the next episode comes around we going
to start answering some listener
questions so if you want a question
answered make sure you leave your
question in the ratings and review
section on Apple podcast under unwax
subscribe to our Spotify we love you
guys we will see you next Tuesday ciao
goodbye